first of all
you know i guess i should apologize i
haven't been back on the tube in weeks
because i've been crazy busy
shooting season 12 of shark tank in
itself which is an extraordinary feat
and i gotta
do a big shout out to cast and crew on
this because we've been doing this whole
thing
in the bubble obviously you know covid19
is causing chaos
in the television production world but
we think
shark tank's a really important platform
because it's not your typical game show
where you throw mud at each other or
something like that
what i'm talking about here is funding
businesses funding companies creating
jobs
getting products to market that need to
get there and that's what we do at
sharktech we're very proud of that
obviously we've been doing it for over a
decade this is season 12.
but in this particular situation
here's here's here's the challenge we've
got
first of all we've got over 265 people
that work on that show
and every single one of them every
single one has to be coveted free
and to do that that's an incredible
logistics challenge they live in
different places
they're all going to go to one bubble a
location that you know has been
kept secret for obvious reasons and once
they go in that bubble they can't leave
but before they go in that bubble they
have to be tested
i'm getting tested every 72 hours as
many many others are but we want to make
sure when we arrive
into the bubble that we are covet-free
because we don't want to give it to each
other
and once we're inside that we're sealed
off we do not go back outside
now just doing that and all the meals
and all the challenges and all the
logistics
you can imagine what that's like but you
know we're halfway through now we're
halfway shooting
and so far so good so you know i don't
we can't say success yet because we're
not done but the point is
i'm now on a break i'm in isolation and
a great time to talk to you
and go through some of the thousands of
questions i've gotten over the last
three weeks that i've been off the air
so to speak
and there's some great themes in there
we're going to talk about but i will say
a couple of things about shark tank
haven't seen
half the pitches so far some big themes
coming because you know america hasn't
been idle sitting in their basements
you know isolating and quarantining
everything else there's some incredible
products so
number one in the categories all kinds
of new
foods healthier foods less sodium less
sugar
plant-based vegan you name it we're
seeing so many food deals i mean
i don't know how many different ways you
can make a hot dog out of chickpeas but
i've seen them all i think
but the point is that's a big theme
number two all kinds of digital services
now
you know america's going through what i
call a digital pivot and it's reflected
in the shark tank deals in other words
nobody's walking in the tank right now
saying hey i've got a great idea for
retail
they're not even thinking about selling
their product or service on retail
anymore they're focused on direct to
customer
and so a lot of the entrepreneurs coming
into the tank have
very very savvy skills on social media
on production on photography on really
rich video
on storytelling you know the ability to
take a new idea
and tell a story in 59 seconds or 29
seconds or 15 seconds
and putting it on all the platforms and
acquiring customers
and using digital to completely be the
universe on under which they sell
they're not even thinking about going to
retail and so that that's another huge
trend we've seen in in the last you know
first half of what we've seen pitched on
shark tank and then the other area which
i find so intriguing
is this new you know
tel tell it the way it is truth there's
no bs anymore no one's coming on coming
into the tank trying to string your
story
they're very honest about you know what
they think is happening in the world and
they're very honest about their ideas on
how they're going to sell their product
and
they're very transparent about the pros
and the cons of the product
usually when people come in and pitch
they're really really hardcore selling
i'm seeing a more you know more empathy
more
empathy for for the situation we're all
in together in this covet thing and it's
a different
vibe so to speak but but those are the
three themes that are streaking through
uh the shark tank production right now
and the products oh my goodness i mean
wait till you see i mean i've got some
deals that just blew my socks off
just incredible stuff and the valuations
how about 50 million that's i think the
biggest
valuation anybody's ever said coming
into a deal with shark tank yeah we had
one of those and i
at the beginning of the pitch said what
this guy's nuts like
and by the time it was over i was an
investor
i mean you know sometimes you see an
idea that's worth 50 million like i'm
not against
great ideas if they have i'm not against
crazy valuations as long as they're
backed by really really really good
ideas that have trajectory of sales so
proven
which in the case of that deal it did
but let's get to the um
the questions okay um i i just got a
mountain of them and and i'm
and i'm trying to group them into um
categories so which i think is helpful
all right so let's start with um one
from jesse
what qualities do you look for when
you're hiring somebody i happen to be
looking for a job right now
list at least three qualities and red
flag
what would disqualify someone no
i think a lot of people are looking for
work so it's a very you know uh
good question a good theme so
here's what you know i've got a huge
portfolio of companies and we're hiring
people all the time
and in our own working group the same
thing what matters to me the most
now is you know first of all
when they present themselves to me have
they done it in a way that's really
succinct because
if it takes more than three paragraphs
on your linkedin resume i happen to use
linkedin a lot
and you can't tell me what benefits you
can bring to me
as an employee i don't want to hire you
so
you should spend a lot of time thinking
about what you say
i don't care where you went to high
school i don't care the name of your dog
i don't care about any of that what i
want to know is you know
what can you do for me or one of my
companies to make
our job easier i'm happy
you know to pay you for that but i want
to know what you bring to the table
and so i generally find the people i
hire
are very quick to focus on why they're
pitching me
i can do this for you i can do that for
you i'm better at this than anybody else
you've ever seen
here's why i think that's true please
give me a shot
number one number two they're willing to
try out first
in other words the idea of being an
apprentice coming in
and working for a while with the team
and be willing to do it maybe as an
intern maybe for 60 or 90 days
you know if they're not willing to do
that i'm willing to do a contract for a
period of let's say
three to six months so so it's a trial
period because
i really want to make sure that they're
willing to integrate and it's going to
be
a successful integration because there's
nothing worse than hiring somebody that
nobody wants to work with
so if they're willing to do that that's
another attribute i like either be
you know an interim with a stipend or or
a contract worker for a period
so we can check each other out and
lastly i i really like to see
somewhere maybe in the third paragraph
or somewhere in
who you are that you embrace the arts in
some way i get business
believe me i get business i understand
the binary nature of business either you
make money or lose it
but i love people that have a little
chaos you know
do they do they play guitar you know
are they are they into
i'm not going to do a concert but i'm
just saying are they
[Music]
can't help myself are they willing to do
something else
besides just business are they into
photography are they into the arts are
they into something else are they into
music
you know do they play an instrument that
to me is a round and balanced person so
that's an attribute i like
i like a lot i think you should stick it
in your resume
because it tells me that you're you're
more than just you know
just focused on the binary nature of
business and i often thought that the
ying and the yang the idea that you're
balanced
it makes you much better more effective
now what do i not like
if i smell [ __ ] on that resume in
any way if you lied to me in any way i
just take that piece of paper
and i never look at it again so do not
talk about degrees you don't have or
things you haven't done
because before you get hired by anybody
not just me they're going to check it
out
and it's really easy to check out online
and i do check you out online and i have
a whole bunch of people that do it too
so if you've got crazy stuff posted
probably not a good idea i mean i feel
empathy for people that are dealing with
drug addiction or alcoholism
but there's no place for that in the
workplace because i don't want my
employees to be affected by that
so that's a big negative too you know
it's just
and if you're dealing with that you need
to clean that up first before you go
work for anybody i know you know you
could say oh that's not right
but it is right because when i bring you
into an environment where other people
are working i want to protect them too
anything to do with you know issues
interpersonal issues in an office i mean
if you can't conduct yourself
professionally and you know what i'm
talking about there is no way i'm hiring
you
so if if you you know you
you take your love life you do that
outside of the office
you do not bring that into the office in
in the wrong way you know exactly what
i'm talking about anything like that
no way my office is a place for people
to work and they have to feel
safe that's what matters so if you're if
you can't
conduct yourself you're asking me what
what are red flags
those are red flags but i want to end
this question on a positive note
i used to say all the time there are
three careers
that i think you know are guaranteed
safe
if you want to get a job number one was
engineering number two is engineering
number three was engineering and if you
want a fourth option
make an engineering but since covet i
want
engineering's still very important but i
want to tell you about another story
here
i have been trying to hire photographers
photographers video editors
people that can tell stories online
people that know
how to do animations and graphics
because the whole world is moving on in
a big digital pivot and storytelling
matters more than ever so
you know people that graduated in the
arts which i used to say well it's
harder to get a job
people that are writers oh it's harder
to get a job people that are
photographers or
or animators or artists or film school
graduates
oh it's hard to get a job not anymore
they are some of the most important
people
to actually employ now because they are
the storytellers of society
they're the ones that know how to create
content
and and i'm looking for those people
those are the people
that are taking content from all of my
companies and i'm going to show you some
later in
in this week's episode of how important
that is and give you real examples of
how to measure the success of them
so you know you know mr wonderful here
has expanded my views about about
it's more than engineering it's orange
engineering with storytelling and that
means the arts are back
and they're back big time so if you're
in one of those programs
i think you have a great opportunity to
really contribute to a team
because teams have to figure out how to
tell stories and tell them online
so a great question let's move on here
all right um oh yeah so
this one is is interesting and i've
i've bundled it with a couple others so
i'll read a couple of questions i've
recently
inherited a decent amount of cash and i
want to invest it make it grow but i'm
nervous about how volatile the stock
market is right now
what can the best and worst investments
a person make in these crazy times
that's mark's question and here's one
from michael i'm 32 and i've managed to
save up around
50 000 bucks like wow
i didn't have 50 grand when i was 32
that's pretty impressive
do i have a chance in hell of making a
million dollar and having a million
dollars saved before retirement
if so how do i do it so those are i'm
going to answer both of these questions
you know let me start by saying
um there's a difference between saving
and investing and what do i mean by that
and i think
this applies to anybody of any age not
just these two questions
when you save money which is a good
thing and you need to have money
cash money for a rainy day or if there's
a catastrophe in the family
that's cash and today cash makes
basically nothing after inflation you're
getting less than one percent
interest when it's sitting in a bank so
that's saving but that's not investing
because
you have to have a plan in your life for
what's going to happen to you when you
hit your 60s and 70s and 80s and maybe
by then your 90s because people are
living longer all the time
how do you get a nest egg together well
the average salary in america is around
fifty eight thousand dollars and so i'm
going to give it to you in a nutshell
you have to start saving in your early
years in your twenties
a 100 bucks a week minimum minimum
but it's not just the saving aspect
you've got to invest that money
so you have to take that hundred dollars
out of whatever your activity is or
you're going to start a side hustle
maybe you're going to be a photographer
maybe you're going to be a writer maybe
you're going to do something else
a separate job where you can make at
least you know 100 bucks a week
after tax and you're going to invest it
you're not going to
save it you're going to invest it
saving is what you have in cash
investing is what you put into the
market
now the market is a volatile thing is
the first question
you know made reference to and when you
invest in the stock market
what matters is diversification you
don't know which stocks are going to go
up and down or when
you don't know which sectors of the
economy are going to outperform the
others you have no idea
but if you look over a long period of
time what you see
is a market a stock market that returns
around six to eight percent a year
and if you start to put aside a hundred
bucks a week in your early years
you're going to end up with you know if
the markets do what they did for the
last hundred plus years
you're end up with about a million and a
half dollars when you're 65.
that is really important so you know
to these questions michael's question
about the fifty thousand dollars he's
got
if that's just being saved well that's
going to lose value each year as
inflation erodes it because inflation's
more
than what interest rates and banks are
now and and for
mark you know yes he does have a chance
because he has to start thinking about
investing
on a broad portfolio now most people
don't even know how to buy and sell
stocks and so
that shouldn't stop them from becoming
investors for their own retirement so
i have spent a whole lot of time working
on something called
bean stocks bean stocks is an app
in your phone and there are many apps
okay there's many apps to help you start
investing
some apps gross up your credit card bill
and put a few cents aside
some apps let you trade stocks and bonds
individually
some apps let you go into the market and
be a day trader that's not what
beanstalks is
i wanted to make something incredibly
simple i wouldn't have
invested in this if i'd found something
that could do it the way i wanted to
i wanted to create an app that anybody
can use to get that hundred bucks put
aside each week
and invest it in the market really
easily and really simply
so what beanstalks does is it lets you
connect to your bank account you can
decide how much you're going to
automatically withdraw each week or you
can put it in manually you decide
it wants to at least put 100 bucks aside
a week that's what makes sense to me
over a long time but then it puts it
into a portfolio
that's already pre-designed for you
using exchange-traded funds
those are called etfs another way of
calling that that are baskets of stocks
baskets of stocks that are good
holds because these etfs are ones
designed to put you into long-term
investments not speculative stuff
stuff that is designed to provide
returns hopefully six to eight percent a
year
in most cases or many cases pay
dividends and and then you reinvest that
those dividends and that's how you grow
that nest egg
but the key is to actually download it
it's free
you can get it from the app store no
matter whether you've got android or
apple whatever you're using
try it and then start to engage
the whole key to this strategy and the
reason i made it so simple was
the hard job for you is to get it in
your head
that you've got to put a hundred dollars
aside each week
now in the case of someone who's got 50
000 like the question we got
just now you want to put that into the
market slowly
you don't want to put it all in at once
maybe you do it over a six-month period
because markets go up and they go down
and you want to average your way in
but the point of being stocks and i keep
saying bean stocks is because
if you don't know how to do this and you
want something incredibly simple to use
that's why i created it i wanted to make
it
really really really easy to do
and that's what beanstalks does so check
it out download it have a look at it
it's very transparent it's a straight
five bucks a month fee
no matter how much you put in so you
know exactly what it costs
and you can watch exactly what's
happening with that portfolio every day
or ignore it
and look at it every month or every
three months but the key is
find a way to save a hundred dollars and
put
put it into beanstalks and let it grow
and you know there's some crap you don't
need to buy
i you know the way i i want you to think
about it pretend i'm on your shoulder
right now i'm on your shoulder and you
walk outside and you're going to buy
some piece of crap you don't need
i'm looking at you barking and saying
don't buy that piece of crap invest it
in your future
do not buy that piece of crap invest in
your future do not spend that hundred
dollars go into your closet look at all
the crap you bought you never wear
look at all the junk around your condo
that you never use
that money should have been invested in
bean stock so it could go to work for
you
that's the whole key to success all
right enough said about that but
i wanted to talk about beanstalks a lot
and i will be because
i've been working on it for a long time
and i really want this to be the core of
my financial
my financial literacy push i'm going to
be doing this year and next year
okay question four you talk a lot about
embracing failure and learning from it
but i find it hard to believe
you failed a lot can you think of a time
when you did fail and what you learned
from it
and what was the biggest mistake you
made well
i have failed a lot many failures i can
give you some
i just gave you one earlier i lost
hundreds and hundreds of thousands of
dollars at least on paper
for a long time shorting yahoo that was
a big mistake stupid of me to do that
then i started a business um you know i
started many startups when i was an
operator that actually failed one was
one was involved with one of the giant
cable companies
and i probably spent about 18 months on
that
made no money lost a lot i think in that
case about
750 000 ouch that hurts
it really stung i've invested in other
deals
some were friends some were other
business associates that went to zero
generally in a startup i'll put up about
250 000
and wait and see what happens then put
more in and there was one that i that i
put 250 into and then within six months
they needed more money
even though my gut was telling me don't
invest in it
i put another 250 and within six months
lost another half million
i've made many mistakes but i learn from
my mistakes
that's the key i am not going to be
successful in everything i do and i want
you to embrace that idea as an
entrepreneur you are not
going to be successful all the time
you will make many many mistakes
and it's okay it's okay as long as you
learn from it now i don't make the same
mistakes anymore i make new mistakes
i learn from those again and that's
what's called experience
the difference between when you start
your career when you get to the middle
of it in the end
is all the mistakes you've made and what
you've learned from them and the older
you get
the more you've learned and that's the
whole idea and when i work with young
entrepreneurs today and with my teams
and my companies
i try and explain to them the mistakes
i've made so they don't make the same
ones
that's the whole idea but it i've made
millions of dollars of mistakes and and
i
you know i once i once ran as a
politician
and lost millions of dollars doing that
was that
was that a mistake was that a learning
experience i'm still haven't decided yet
but it's sort of it's sort of
those experiences in life are are made
up the patina of life
the rest of life the coding of life is
is all the experiences
not just the successes but the failures
you've made
now do i like losing money no do i cry
like a baby when it happens yes
because i know how hard it is to make it
really hard
and i hate to lose it but i make sure
that i
i i distill the essence of that lesson
that's very very important and and i i
just i want to encourage everybody with
a question like that
to embrace failure it's not that you
alone have failed it's that the idea
didn't have
merit the attempt didn't work for
whatever reason the market wasn't ready
for it
you know even in relationships maybe you
weren't meant to be together in the end
i mean there's a whole
there's a whole concept of life around
karma and things that should happen and
things that shouldn't but should you
fail yes
yes yes you should otherwise you will
have no experiences
okay um you know that's an important
answer i think to the issue of failure
now
this one is is something i do want to
talk about this week
i was watching you last week on an early
morning tv show
talking about your shark tank companies
and what they were doing to survive
during the pandemic
and you kept talking about a digital
pivot what did you mean
now let me give you an example i started
giving an example here's one
you remember this deal it's called
bertello pizza ovens
here's the moment i closed it on shark
tank have a look at this
chef wonderful has found the best pizza
oven in the world of patello i can't
wait to get behind this
everybody in america is going to be
making incredible pizza
i just love it i feel warm and fuzzy 600
degrees
okay now are we going to sell a lot of
pizza ovens
when they're in in retail no no no no we
had to pivot like everybody else
so what did we do this is one example of
working with your company now one of the
things a shark is really good at
and you know and that i focus my time
and energy on with my companies
how can i use my social media platform
to acquire customers for my companies
i mean that's the magic of shark tank
shark tank is the best venture capital
firm in the world
why because through syndication 10
million people see the show
you can't buy that kind of exposure and
then through social media for the
millions of people that are following me
i like to promote my companies because
i'm an investor in them
i believe in the entrepreneurs i believe
in the product or service and i want
them to be successful
so what did we do in the case of
bertello we started thinking all right
how do we get this product to customers
who are not going to sell it in retail
well what happens to people that are
quarantined
during covet well they're hanging out in
their backyards they're hanging out in
their balconies they're hanging out with
their families
and what better thing to do together
than make a pizza
it's fun it's crazy fun i have a
bratello i use it practically every day
i love it it's so much fun and it's
great with your family to make pizzas
and so we said
how can we tell that story how can we
tell that story about the patello pizza
oven
and who can we tell it to then it hit me
great partner of mine qvc six million
people watching qvc live
what about if we did a live pizza party
on qvc with the patello oven
what if i taped a 59 second video
and did it and showed it live while i
was talking about the pizza oven
direct maybe from my own backyard but
you can cook a pizza in about 90 seconds
this thing gets unbelievably hot and
will use
either propane or wood
or pellets from your traeger or it can
use
charcoal and it is an amazing way to
cook your pizza the stone gets super hot
and when you go to pull out these pizzas
that cook in 90 seconds
this is the kind of pizza pie i'm gonna
walk it over here so our camera can
shoot down on it
so you can really see that this is wood
fired pizza or propane fired pizza or
charcoal-fired pizza it cooks literally
in about 90 seconds you have to turn it
and rotate it what about every 25
seconds
yeah about every 15 seconds actually
mary said so this is going to be
perfect for you what we want to do is
show you
kevin o'leary aka mr wonderful in action
with this pizza oven here we go now
the moment of truth let's take one of
these
slices of pie with all the cheese
dripping down
[Music]
and
[Music]
oh that
is incredible i see you're ripping me
off on my idea with the olive oil
actually dad i'm pretty sure this was my
[Laughter]
idea
sloppy and delicious crazy good it's
just beyond fantastic
this reminds me of paris at night i'm
not kidding it's romantic
the flavors are so spectacular this
could be the best
piper made now i got to make a better
pie see you soon
get your patello and let's make pie
kevin o'leary is joining us live via
skype
kevin i know you're super excited about
this pizza oven
we saw the clip on shark tank and which
will show i've seen the clip and i know
we'll show it here in the presentation
this is an amazing way for you to have
wood-fired pizza in your own backyard
david of all my shark tank investments
and i've been on the show for 12 years
i've never had more fun than with this
pizza oven
the kids love it the family loves it
everybody loves it
and the only thing that stops creativity
is your imaginations i've made
every kind of pie known to man and i'm
still inventing new ones you can see
what i'm doing right here
and not only that david here's a little
secret besides how oh
i'm just i just finished this beautiful
pepperoni
lucky oh my goodness i know
but wait wait wait david look at this i
made
sweet potato fries on it as well i go
beyond pizza this thing is fantastic
oh my goodness hey kevin i need to let
everybody know we have only 350 of these
to go around that we can ship out right
now when those sell out we're going
to go to an advanced order but this is
going very quickly and it's free
shipping and handling day if there was
ever a day for you to buy
a pizza oven it's today now real quickly
we're going to take a look at the shark
tank clip and then we'll go over to mary
who's quickly cooking pizzas
away from me on on on the other side of
the driveway here
but let's first go to our shark tank
clip and show you what really turned
kevin o'leary's head when he saw this in
action
i also have an offer really it's you
eric
and a bunch of money required for
inventory and probably
more optimization on digital that you've
never done okay
um but i want 30 percent
would you do it for 25 percent yes well
we'd love to take a deal
i don't believe it i won't step in that
but
i've got to be careful congratulations
guys
so last weekend in eight minutes
we sold a thousand bertello pizza ovens
i mean i couldn't think of a better
outcome in eight minutes
because we were able to do the digital
pivot we were able to tell the story
show the product
work with a partner like qvc direct to
customers that bought it
people love this oven that's what i'm
talking about that's the digital pivot
i'm talking about
and now you've seen an example of how it
works i don't just do that for patello i
do with
all my companies that's why shark tank
is so
powerful if you can partner with a shark
and you can start to do a digital pivot
you can sell direct to customers
millions of them are out there watching
if you can get to them
how do you do it you have to understand
how the social media algorithms work you
have to know how to tell
a story in 15 seconds 29 seconds 59
seconds
in some cases 2 minutes and 20 seconds
depending on which digital platform
you're on
but that means great photography great
video
really good storytelling fantastic
animations
all of that comes together and that's
how it works and now you understand the
secret sauce of shark tank
and the bertello and by the way if you
want a great pizza oven i'm always a
salesman i love this patella pizza
and you obviously you see that it's more
fun than you can ever have cooking it is
absolutely great
and who's the best pizza guy in the
world now it's me i can make a pie
that you die for
[Music]
you